[Musique]
tous ces modèles comme aux Bahamas, le
festival le plus fou que le monde ait jamais
vu, une
escapade sur une île s'est transformée en catastrophe, c'est devenu
très barbare, attendez de voir
ce que vous vous embarquez dans
les rappeurs américains, notre règle n'est pas les
Bahamas avec son  partenaire commercial vraiment
MacFarlane est un entrepreneur incroyable, il
pourrait convaincre n'importe qui de presque tout
ce qu'ils viennent d'acheter une île L'île de
Pablo Escobar oh mon dieu, nous
allons organiser un festival ouais dans les 48
heures, ils ont vendu ces gars-là
soit complètement plein de merde ou leur
les gars les plus intelligents dans la pièce nous
travaillions 24 heures sur 24 pas de sommeil
Lily est comme amener plus de travailleurs nous avons besoin de
plus de travailleurs chaque jour les gars plus de
tentes il ne prendrait tout simplement pas non pour une
réponse et il a juste continué à tirer de l'argent d'une
manière ou d'une autre des gens désespérés font des
choses désespérées  il mentait aux investisseurs
et donnait l'impression que nous gagnions une tonne
d'argent que
nous n'étions pas je veux dire que c'est de la fraude dont nous avons besoin
pour faire passer le message maintenant  t ce
n'est pas un festival de musique de luxe oh mon dieu
il y a des matelas partout qui
se font tremper le mode sauve-toi bien
lancé c'est un libre pour tous c'est
devenu cette mentalité de pillage il y a une
foule en colère ils sont énervés et ils
veulent  leur argent des modèles puissants ont construit
ce festival, puis une photo de
fromage sur du pain grillé a déchiré le festival,
ils ne pouvaient tout simplement pas s'adapter physiquement à
beaucoup de gens sur l'île, le
co-fondateur de l'événement risque jusqu'à 20 ans de
prison si vous aviez des milliers de  dollars
le départ en voyage pour voir clignoter 182 c'est
sur vous c'est le darwinisme à son meilleur
le plus grand événement depuis des décennies je
vous promets que je serai là
[Musique]
vous